there's rumors that you're engaged mama
june what do you say to that well look
baby i've had this ring on my hand
for nine years um i have been you know
what i'm saying turns out mama june is a
married woman after secretly getting
hitched to her boyfriend justin stroud
back in march i'm happy where i'm at
today i'm very happy in the relationship
i mean i'm happy the person i become
happy in my relationships across the
board the deputy court clerk in
wilkinson county georgia confirms to et
that mama june whose real name is june
shannon tied the knot with justin at a
local courthouse on march 23rd and get
this they secretly married the same
month that they sparked engagement
rumors when they were seen shopping at a
jewelry store
however when et spoke to mama june in
may she denied taking their relationship
to the next level i've had this ring on
my hand
for nine years um i have been you know
i'm saying so there is no different
marine because he was like oh you know
look kate is my favorite jewelry store
and who knows what the future holds
honestly
um so we're gonna see mama june told et
they started dating in 2021 after
meeting in a somewhat unconventional way
we met on somebody's tick tock in the
back
wait what do you mean like in the
comments
no he was live with somebody and like if
i was sitting right here he was like
behind me like on this side and there
were some other people behind him and
then um i don't know just i just would
have started like chit chatting and
um i started kind of like stalking him
everybody always said he's a clown
chaser i was chasing him
okay so it was you who kind of made the
first move yes yes but get this when
they met mama june said justin didn't
know who she was
mama june you've been on our tv screens
for over a decade at this point are you
telling us 11 years on october 12th oh
my gosh are you telling me after nearly
11 years in the you know public space
justin didn't know who you were
no
one thing that's bonded the couple
recovery they're both leading sober
lives which plays out on the newest
season of mama june road to redemption
there's days that i want to get high
and mama june says being on this journey
together is only strengthening their
connection you know you just got to be
supportive like when there is days
because disciples people can come clean
does not mean
the mental it doesn't become peaches
flowers and rainbows now people out here
will say well two active two recovering
addicts cannot people in recovery cannot
be together well that's a lie we're
gonna prove that that little five
percent of the relationships don't work
we've been through hell and back we've
known each other for a year most
relationships don't go through
the obstacles that we have had to go
through the last year and they don't
even go through it in their lifetime of
their relationship so i think honestly
that's made us stronger
[Music]
you